لصد الهجمات اليمنيه تلابيب تعلن عن تحالف
جديد يضم دولا عظمى وواشنطن تضع موعدا
لنهايه الحرب في القطاع خطه عبريه للتخلص
من انفاق القطاع ترتيب جديد تموله
الامارات وامريكا يستهدف باب المندب وعلى
غير العاده عقوبات امريكيه على المستوطنات
العبريه لبنان يعاود هجماته على التجمعات
العبريه وافتتاح لاكبر مفاعل اندماج نووي
في اليابان الدفاع البريطانيه تسجل عجزا
بعشرات المليارات من الدولارات ولمواجهه
الاسطول الصيني واشنطن تدخل سلاحا اضافيا
على قوتها البحريه الصحافه البريطانيه
لندن تستعد لاجبار كياب على التفاوض مع
روسيا وموسكو ترحب دول اوروبيه ترفض
انضمام اوكرانيا للاتحاد وموعد الغاء
ترامب تسليم الاسلحه
لاوكرانيا جبهه جديده للقطاع
بعد ان سببت الكثير من الصداع للجيش
العبري ولم يجد حلا لاجتيازها عن انفاق
القطاع نتحدث لتفيد صحيفه و ستريت جورنال
بان الجيش العبري يدرس فكره غمر انفاق
الفصائل في القطاع بمياه البحر واكدت ان
المضخات قادره على دخل المياه من البحر
الابيض المتوسط لاغراق الانفاق خلال
اسابيع قليله في المقابل قالت صحيفه يودي
عوت احرنوت ان مدينه خانيونس جنوب القطاع
من المحتمل ان اجعل تلبيب تدفع ثمنا اكبر
مما دفعته بالشمال داعيه الى خفض التوقعات
بشان العمليه العسكريه حتى ان هيئه البث
العبريه قالت ان الولايات المتحده حددت
لتل ابيب حتى بدايه العام المقبل لانهاء
الحرب على القطاع ولاجل امان البحر توجهت
تلبيب بشكل رسمي الى عده دول بينها
بريطانيا واليابان بهدف تشكيل قوه عمليه
مخصصه للعمل في البحر الاحمر من اجل ضمان
حريه الممرات الملاحيه هناك حسب وسائل
اعلام عبريه فيما قالت وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه ان الهجمات التي شنها الحوثيون
ربما لا تستهدف السفن الحربيه الامريكيه
رغم ان البحريه الامريكيه ردت باسقاط
طائرات مسيره وصواريخ في الاسابيع الماضيه
على ذات السياق قالت صحيفه نيزا في سيميا
الروسيه ان هناك مساع جديه في الامارات
والولايات المتحده لتسليح الفصائل
المدعومه من ابوظبي وفي اليمن لمواجهه
هجمات الحوثي
في البحر الاحمر ضد السفن العبريه ودوليا
وصف رئيس تشيلي جابرييل بوريتش تصرفات
حكومه رئيس الوزراء العبري بنيامين
نتنياهو في القطاع بالقسوه الوحشيه بسبب
مقتل عدد كبير من الاطفال هذا واكد الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان خلال كلمته في
القمه الخليجيه وجوب اقامه دوله فلسطينيه
مستقله عاصمتها القدس الشرقيه وشدد
اردوغان على ضروره الوصول الى وقف دائم
لاطلاق النار في القطاع فيما كشف مسؤولون
امريكيون رفيعي المستوى عن ملامح خطه
اداره بايدن لما بعد الحرب في القطاع
ونقلت صحيفه بوليتيكو ان المسؤولين في
البيت الابيض ووزاره الخارجيه ووكالات
اخرى يقودهم منسق البيت الابيض لشؤون
الشرق الاوسط امضوا اسابيع في صياغه هذه
اللحظه التي تشمل زياده مساعدات واشنطن
الامنيه للسلطه الفلسطينيه كما تمنح الخطه
دورا اكبر للمنسق الامني الامريكي من جانب
اخر ذكر موقع اكسيوس نقل عن مسؤولين
امريكيين انه من المتوقع ان تفرض واشنطن
عقوبات على مستوطنين عبريين متورطين في
هجمات ضد المدنيين مع منعهم من السفر الى
الولايات المتحده هنا عاودت لبنان هجماتها
العسكريه حيث اعلنت مقاومه لبنان عن
مهاجمته ثمانيه مواقع عسكريه عبريه قباله
الحدود الجنوبيه للبنان وقالت المقاومه ان
مقاتليها استهدفوا تجمعين للجنود العبريين
في موقع رويس العاصي وفي مثلث الطيحات
قباله القطاع الاوسط بالجنوب اللبناني
وبعيدا عن الحرب افتتح اكبر مفاعل اندماج
نووي تجريبي في العالم في اليابان في
انجاز ما يزال في مهده ولكنه وصف بانه
الحل لاحتياجات البشريه المستقبليه من
الطاقه وياتي المفاعل كمشروع مشترك بين
الاتحاد الاوروبي واليابان الذي يعد
بمثابه مشروع رائد لمشروع اكبر في فرنسا
اما في بريطانيا تعاني وزاره الدفاع من
عجز قدره
21.4 مليار دولار في ميزانيه التجهيزات
جراء التضخم والمطالب في استراتيجيه
الحكومه المحدثه وفق ما اعلن المكتب
الوطني لمراجعه الحسابات اما في امريكا
فافد وكاله بلومبرج بان القوات البحريه
الامريكيه تخطط لتسليح غواصاتها ابتداء من
العام المقبل بنسخه مضاده للسفن من صواريخ
توما هاك لتعزيز القدرات في مواجهه
الاسطول الصيني كما ذكرت ان اليابان قد
تحصل ايضا على هذه الصواريخ في
المستقبل ر رغبه
اوروبيه هل يرغب الاوروبيون بضم اوكرانيا
لاتحاد الواقع يقول عكس ما تتمناه كياف
هنا دع رئيس الوزراء الهنغار فيكتور
اوربان الاتحاد الاوروبي الى عدم محاوله
البدء بالمفاوضات حول عضويه اوكرانيا في
القمه المقبله في بروكسل بحسب بلومبرج
فيما اعلن وزير الخارجيه سلوفاكي يوراي
بلاناريا لا يمكنه تصور اوكرانيا عضوا في
الاتحاد الاوروبي مشيرا الى ان العضويه
المحتمله لهذا البلد بالاتحاد بعيده جدا
جدا من جهتها قالت صحيفه الديلي اكسبرس ان
دبلوماسيين بريطانيين يستعدون لاجبار
اوكرانيا على التفاوض مع روسيا لانهاء
النزاع المسلح الدائر حاليا هنا قال
المتحدث باسم الرئاسه الروسيه ديمتري
بيسكوف في حديث تلفزيوني ان روسيا ستبقى
مستعده للمفاوضات بشان اوكرانيا وتفضل
موسكو الوسائل السياسيه والدبلوماسيه وفي
سياق اخر قال المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه ماثيو ميلر ان الولايات المتحده
تعتبر وضع اوكرانيا صعبا نظرا لان الاموال
المخصصه للاداره الامريكيه لدعم كياف
ستنفد قريبا جدا هناك كتبت صحيفه امريكيه
ان المرشح الرئاسي الجمهور دونالد ترامب
قد يلغي تسليم الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا في
اليوم الاول من ولايته الجديده في حال فاز
بالانتخابات واشارت الصحيفه اذا عاد ترامب
فان اجماع النيتو على المضي قدما في عرض
كياف سيكون غير مرجح ميدانيا اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها اسقطت طائرتين
حربيتين اوكرانيين ومروح خلال 24 ساعه
فيما بلغت خسائر الجيش الاوكراني اليوميه
نحو
695 جنديا واضافت الوزاره الروسيه ان
قواتها دمرت 26 طائره بدون طيار اوكرانيه
واعترضت 15 اخرى فوق بحر ازوف وشبه جزيره
القرم خلال الليل واشارت الوزاره ايضا عن
قيام القوات المسلحه الروسيه بتوجيه ضربات
دقيقه ادت الى تدمير معدات تابعه للواء ال
62 وال 68 الاوكرانيين على محور لوغانسك
مضيفه ان القوات الروسيه قصفت مستودع
الاسلحه التابع للواء الدفاعي الاقليمي
الاوكراني رقم
124 بالقرب من مدينه خيرسون فضلا عن دحر
العديد من الجنود الاوكرانيين واستهداف
المعدات العسكريه للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه في 103
مناطق
[موسيقى]
ا
ه